[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
as always I've got a co-host who's a
stand-up comedian Paul Mercurio Paul
welcome back to start talk nice to see
you again Neil great to be back and I'd
like I can count you as my friend that
we had a couple of lunches together and
so yeah more than just my co-host yeah
you treat us to a great lunch and the
three of us need to do that again soon
we were talking about that that was
really yeah excellent excellent and so
also just some people if they don't
otherwise know you or they know you only
a little bit uh I first knew of your
work as the warm-up guy for the audience
for for Colbert's The Late Show then I
see clips of you do and stand up on the
show yes it is me yeah I'm a big shot I
don't think you realize that and uh I'm
the one would call me an international
Superstar at least that one that one
person would be me yeah or your mother
yeah or my mother no I was when I left
Wall Street to be a comedian so I'm just
I think the word she's is Disappointment
but
um yeah no I mean Stephen and I go back
to the Daily Show together I was a
writer performer on that show and
excellent and so yes I've been part of
that DNA of of those shows for a while
but yeah yeah that's where we got to
know each other and excellent you always
you're always great on the show you're
always oh thank you thank you just as a
guest uh so today we're tackling the big
questions
the big questions and that could mean
different things to different people but
on this show it means the big questions
in the universe and we we combed the
world no we call them the universe and
we found someone who's who just
published a book titled existential
physics
scientist Guide to the biggest questions
and that person is in the house right
now except
dialing in from Germany we have Sabina
Hassan Felder do I pronounce that right
Sabina that was wonderful good to see
you guys excellent excellent uh you're a
theoretical physicist uh and and Paul
it's not that she's theoretically a
physicist I just want to clarify that
okay she's a theoretical physicist a
research fellow at the Frankfurt
Institute of advanced studies of course
in Germany and you've got a popular
YouTube channel called science without
the gobbledygook how could you not tune
into that with a name such as that and
one of my favorite works of hers is an
earlier book that was indicting the
expectation that elegance and beauty and
math should guide science and it I I
agree Sabina with you a hundred percent
that it has often derailed what could be
an actual Discovery because we we lace
our own our own uh expectations on what
the universe should be could you just
comment on that briefly
yeah um it's an ongoing disaster it's
still happening it's not like yeah it's
over yeah so my first book uh dealt with
um the question why there's been pretty
much no progress in the foundations of
physics in the past 50 years or so since
the standard model was completed so we
we've gotten stuck with all those big
questions what is dark matter what stock
energy how did the universe begin and
you know
the standard model is it's the it's the
array of particles that we know exist in
the universe and how they all fit
together how they interact and what
forces they they uh enact upon each
other and that was quite an achievement
coming out you know in the in the mid to
late 20th century and you're saying it
hasn't been much fundamental progress
since then
for what does theory development is
concerned no so um since the the time
that the standard model was completed uh
so in the mid 1970s or something
um Loosely speaking
um there have been a lot of experimental
discoveries a lot of the particles in
the standard model had not been observed
at the time like for example the heavier
quarks and stuff like this of course the
Higgs which wasn't exposure I can't
leave that out right exactly right which
was only experimentally confirmed uh 10
years ago right it just had the 10-year
anniversary but for what the
mathematical structure is concerned uh
it hasn't changed
um don't feel alone about this we
haven't been back to the Moon in 50
years okay so you're not the only one is
that because that so much information
came out of that first tranche of
discovery that it just sort of
processing all of those different
elements of knowledge just takes so much
time that it's hard to sort of
advance to another tranche is it could
is that one particular reason Maybe
well the message that I'm trying to get
across on the book is that the problem
is the physicists got too Enchanted by
certain ideals of beauty
um so what happened after this event her
answer is no to that question
by the way translate for the record
Sabina I was this close to writing that
book you beat me to the punch by like
like an hour I was I had it almost all
done and then yours came out and I'm
like you know what forget it I'm not
going to bother what's an example of of
a the most one of the most distracting
uh uh Beauty elements that people want
to be true in the universe
unification I guess so after this
standard model was completed
um there were a lot of physicists who
thought it should be more unified they
were looking for this grant unified
theory uh which was pretty you know at
the time I think at the 70s 80s they
thought it was pretty much around the
corner and it's out of this Spirit uh
that string theory was born and all the
what happened was that all the
predictions that were made from those
theories were falsified to the extent
that they could be falsified so now
we're left with the non-falsifiable
ideas
um yeah so it was Grant unification also
symmetry super symmetry this is a good
traditional Einstein
was was headed there right so you don't
want to be in the in the in the wake of
Einstein's work well for one thing I I
think Einstein wasn't driven by symmetry
um although it's certainly true that the
way that we understand uh general
relativity today uh it's based on
symmetries but I think it wasn't it was
neinstein's uh intention but so what
happened was that um I think in the 70s
80s relying on symmetries was the next
natural thing to do it had worked before
so of course you do it again
um but the the problem was it didn't
work and physicists just didn't learn
the lesson so instead of saying okay we
tried it it didn't work let's move on
and try something different they tried
the same thing over and over and over
again and basically they're still trying
it so how's it surprising that there's
no progress
um
so I I bet you're you're popular at
their parties yeah I'm grateful
you get a lot of them my invitation must
have been lost in the mail exactly so is
it is it because they lack the security
of their own analysis that they keep
testing it over and over again I mean is
it is it I mean you know they're not
insane right there must be some
rationale in their mind that they they
keep retesting the same so maybe there's
doubt in their own mind about their
processes or their analysis
yeah I think that's not one factor to it
but uh a couple of them which is why my
book has 300 pages so right if it was
that shortened answer it wouldn't have
been worth writing a book so I think
it's partly
um a lack of understanding of the
philosophy of science so I think that
they're not really thinking about what's
going on so they don't recognize it's
not working and they try the same thing
over and over again even though good
scientists you know you choose should
use the scientific method and uh not do
this kind of thing but it's also I think
it's it's a community problem it's kind
of baked into the way
um that academic communities work and
the way that they are funded it's just
really really hard to get out of some
kind of research Direction after you've
spent a significant time of your career
on it and do something else there are
very few physicist and I know some of
them so they exist who said Okay so
we've tried super symmetry it doesn't
work uh I'll stop it and do something
else because it makes your life very
very difficult if you do this because
all your funding goes out of the window
and then your your whole track record
has evaporated so it's like being a
one-trick pony like Def Leppard right
like it's like sort of just the same
song over and over you kind of get
locked into it yeah you know I I wrote
in the piece for I think it was uh
what's the UK saying physics physics
world is this the yeah uh right I could
keep physics today is the US One in
position UK one yeah so I wrote
something for physics word and I wrote
uh advice for postdocs don't don't be a
one-trick pony and my British friend
this is such an American idiom
uh well I'm a one-trick pony that's why
I said it so I just say this so what's
Def Leppard's one trick pony uh no it's
their songs everything sounds the same
oh everything sounds the same over and
over and over again it's the same thing
yeah so Sabina so that early work uh
that early book really puts you in a
good way and it positions you to take on
uh a broader topic here so the
existential questions and and uh so what
what prompted you to write this book
oh my first book is like really
depressing I mean I I was basically
going on for those 300 pages about why
there's no progress in the foundation of
physics and and trying to explain what
everybody else is doing wrong which you
know doesn't exactly make me look like a
particularly nice person and it kind of
I I felt that it was necessary to write
the book because I thought someone's got
to say it you know it there's no reason
why the LHC should be seeing new
particles all the all those stories that
they've told about let's see the Large
Hadron Collider yeah exactly that thing
um you know there have been all those
stories they would see supersymmetric
particles or dark matter it would make
black holes and all that kind of stuff
and all those suppose predictions were
based on arguments from Beauty and in in
my book I explained this but you know it
kind of makes me this person who's
always complaining about what other
people do and uh I'm kind of unhappy
with the picture that I've painted of
myself so
um I was thinking uh you know I I would
try to remind myself why I studied
physics in the first place which is that
I was really intrigued by how much you
can learn about nature from pure
mathematics basically you know all those
symmetries that we were just talking
about they're like really really
powerful tools that have taught us so
much about how the universe works and a
lot of those stories haven't really been
told to the public like when it comes to
those big existential questions
and so I've collected them in my book
good so you saw a gap that you're
filling excellent excellent so we got
questions we solicited questions from
our yes our our patreon fan base and
these are supporters of the show and
they get their questions on so
apparently you have to actually become a
patreon member in order to even get your
question looked at much less selected so
that's kind of cold I think but that's
how that's how that works I didn't set
up that rule just just let you know our
producers and other folks who pay the
bills set up that rule okay so so Paul
once you start off you've got the
questions I haven't seen them or heard
them and I don't think Sabina has seen
them correct so there's some really
great questions this uh this time around
so we're going to jump in with Quentin
on microwaves hi do we know where these
people are from from Switzerland this is
uh tell us where they're from why you
leave that out I was about to say hi
greetings from Switzerland
Switzerland is where the LHC is so this
person is like on top of the situation
yeah I was reading his thing and it said
hi guys greeting from Switzerland uh you
see the tension Sabina this is how this
goes all right what's more knowledge is
what more knowledge is there to gain by
making more and more detailed
measurements of the cosmic microwave
background love the show I'll take the
thing that everyone is looking
um after at the moment are the B modes
right they want to measure the
polarization uh of the CMB to try and
figure out uh if there were
gravitational waves in the early
universe
are you saying that there's nothing in
there that can help you and your dark
matter search in the CMB
um well me and my dark matter search
exactly exactly what are you talking
about
are we all looking for dark matter like
my personal satellite had just launched
no so uh yeah I mean so the CMB does put
constraints on dark matter it's been
doing this for some time and every time
the data gets better than the the
parameters of Lambda CDM shift around
for a little bit and people adjust their
models
um I don't think the CMB is the best
tool to learn something about dark
matter because it's just you know the
overall Dark Matter friction of the
universe is one of those parameters but
what you really want to know like where
where um the
the properties of the Dark Matter stuff
if it's stuff become important is more
on the smaller scares galaxies Galaxy
clusters when you have to take into
account how how the stuff actually
clumps
um and there are some things that you
can do in the CMB
um Loosely speaking because
um those structures give rise to
gravitational lenses so it distorts the
CMB and there's a fancy name for it
which escapes me at the moment but this
is how it goes with my brain
um and and you can look for this
um so this is interesting but it has
fairly large error bars um so um I I
think that this stuff with the B modes
is more exciting if you want to
understand how the universe evolves so I
have a slightly different outlook on
that Sabina but we're going to get to
that right when we come back from a
break we'll take our first break from
cosmic queries the big questions and our
special guest dialing in from uh what
town are you in right now Sabina
Heidelberg Heidelberg Heidelberg dialing
in from Heidelberg great memories of
Heidelberg
husenfelder we'll be we'll be right back
and we'll learn maybe what
Paul did in a Heidelberg when we come
back to start talk you don't want to
know
we're back segment two Cosmic queries
we're talking about the big questions
and the release of Sabina hasenfelder's
book Sabina give me the full title it's
like existential
existential physics a scientist's guide
to Life's biggest questions there you go
there you go and it's just always good
to have someone in Arm's Reach with that
kind of expertise because you just never
know but by the way I have a book coming
out peanut butter do you need jelly or
don't you yeah no I'm with you on that
I'm with peanut it doesn't need jelly
I'm all good with the peanut butter it's
400 Pages it's a very deep analysis
sorry Sabine it's going to be competing
with your book I hope yours works out
but that's all I'm saying right all
right let's kill let's keep moving so
before the break Paul we got this
question from this uh person in
Switzerland wanting to know whatever
more detail uh measurements of the
Cosmic microwave background can do for
us here's what I would say Sabina that
if I'm at a distance and I see at home
and I see a region around the home
that's all green
and I say oh that's that's like a green
carpet or something okay but then I get
closer or I look with higher resolution
and they say no wait a minute
they're Blades of grass there and then
I'd say okay so it's a green thing made
of Blade so Chris and I look even closer
wait the blades of grass have cells in
them right and so every next layer I
would not have even known to ask if that
was there until I had that extra
resolution
that empowered me to to inquire in ways
I had not previously imagined
so are you prepared to say that a higher
even higher resolution of the customer
microwave background there's nothing
there for us like looking at a lawn of
grass no of course I would never say
that you never know what you're going to
find
um it's just my guess that uh we we will
have a bigger turnout from the B modes
uh than from a higher resolution Cosmic
microwave background okay all right can
I ask like why why is it that CMB gives
us information about the nature of the
universe just after the big bang but not
the last scattering what is and is there
any been is there a movement on that
well you know the phrase just after the
big bang is kind of ambiguous
um because that's the best thing I can
do I'm a comedian all the interesting
things that happened in the early
Universe are right after the big bang
like in in the first like 10 to the
minus 10 seconds or something like this
right right so I'm afraid you have to be
a little a bit more specific
[Laughter]
so so I guess the point is the the
cosmic microwave background is several
hundred thousand years after the big
bang right 380 000 right of what it
unfolded before then and so it gives us
a some insight into an earlier time but
maybe not as far back as your otherwise
indicating as your other was indicating
uh I mean so so what you say is of
course entirely correct
um it's kind of difficult to see
through through all this plasma which is
opaque
um there are several things that people
have proposed I mean looking for those
gravitational waves then the B modes it
kind of allows you to look back to
earlier times uh at least if you trust
the interpretation uh people have also
uh suggested to look for the neutrino
Cosmic microwave background which should
be there so they they have traveled
undisturbed for a longer time but the
problem with the neutrinos is well they
interact very weakly so um you know a
good nose how long it would take to
measure the thing like maybe we'd be
measuring I don't know 100 000 gears or
something so I don't expect results
anytime soon yeah neutrinos have always
been very difficult uh they they don't
play well with others I think no they
don't at all so Paul give me some more
questions yeah this is on wave function
from Stephen Murphy I'm not sure where
this person is from but uh I understand
quantum physics correct if I if I
understand quantum physics correctly
there is something about measurements
that collapses the wave function some
people especially sci-fi authors seem to
believe are conscious observation of the
measurement is what does the collapsing
how do we know that our our observation
is not the key factor I think we know I
think there's an esteemed scientist Dr
Emmett Brown from Back to the Future who
said if you traveled but in the past and
you play with the past you're going to
alter the future so I think we could
just move on we could just move on yes
exactly we don't need Sabina to answer
look so Sabina what do you have there
this this this uh collapse of the wave
function
also
as of quantum mechanics like when the
thing came up uh it became clear that
there's something
um going on in in the measurement they
didn't know what uh and they made what's
now known as the Heisenberg cut which
basically says wave function does one
thing when you're not looking at it and
when you do look at it booms it
collapses into something that
corresponds to our classical reality
um I don't think that today
um anybody believes this or I mean
maybe I shouldn't put it that strongly
but they're probably one or two weird
people who still believe that
Consciousness has something to do with
the collapse of the wave function but uh
certainly the the vast majority of
businesses have abandoned this idea
simply because we know that we can make
Quantum measurements without the
involvement of any conscious
Observer we can do it with some kind of
apparatus that was programmed by a
computer on in the student future maybe
we can do it with robots or maybe this
is already happy and I haven't
gotten the memo
um so what do we what do we mean what do
we need Consciousness for basically in
the moment you just missed a d a
discovery it's that the machines making
the measurement are conscious it's
obvious all right yeah so there's
evidence called pan psychism though
exactly
yeah could you how could you have missed
that that Revelation there come on yeah
right but um so maybe more interestingly
it's like the the opposite uh
combination that
um quantum mechanics play some kind of
role for Consciousness it has not
completely gone out of the window maybe
most prominently it's represented by
Roger Penrose who thinks that
um something about those Quantum
processes and the measurement
um the collapse of the wave function
particular is necessary to give rise to
Consciousness in the human brain and I'm
not at all convinced by this but then he
has won the Nobel Prize and I haven't
if he wanted for black holes not for not
for right you know Consciousness just to
be clear yeah so what is he so what does
he know yeah
everybody can have a no but I I have one
I gotta know yeah he's one of the most
eminent Among Us in the in the physics
and astrophysics Universe Roger Penrose
still alive still at it and I think he's
old enough so he can have some uh
borderline flaky ideas and you still end
up giving it some respect and so I think
uh Sabina that's where that's where you
were Landing there I think I mean you
know by all chances I just don't
understand it
time exists in black holes this is uh
from Queensland Queensland Peter Jacobs
Australia where is uh where it is uh a
different time and a different day and
293 degrees this winter morning this is
what Peter says all right here's this
question does time exist in a black hole
and if you travel through a wormhole
could you end up in a different place in
time and not be able
to get back well I don't know if you're
going to do air travel by the way Peter
right now you're not getting it you're
not going anywhere because your voice is
going to be canceled so
you're not traveling through any
Wormhole anywhere anytime try taking it
anytime soon anytime soon exactly so
Sabina what happens what's the fate of
someone
in a wormhole and in a black hole other
than that they'll ripped apart and die
and pull aside that complication
I'm still trying to digest the phrase a
different place in time but I think I
think I know what it means yeah so um
the weird thing about Einstein's theory
is that he made time into a coordinate
like space
um and it has the consequence that the
labels on those coordinates
um are kind of ambiguous you can change
them the same way that you can change
the labels on your ruler from I don't
know inch to centimeters or something
like this they don't really mean
anything
um so this coordinate time
um has to be enjoyed with a lot of care
if you want to interpret it usually what
we deal with in Einstein's theory is
What's called the proper time so this is
the time that an observer would
experience who would be traveling in
this space-time and for we know if you
fall into a black hole or if you go
through a wormhole then your proper time
just moves forward so you get older
where you come out in this coordinate
time uh is a completely different
question and indeed if you go through a
wormhole you could in principle come out
in the past according to this um
coordinate time and this is also why a
lot of businesses believe that wormholes
are hugely problematic because they
could lead to all kinds of products as
you could go back in time kill your
grandfather that kind of story
and why is everyone always talking about
killing their their ancestors why not
just prevent them from meeting and then
they don't marry and have babies I've
always got to kill them right I mean
what what's you know or you go back and
you ask that girl or that guy out that
you wanted to ask out on a date and you
didn't and you were and then you ended
up in with the person you're with and
that's not working out I'm getting too
personal right now yeah yeah I don't
hear your your issues because Sabina my
wife and I are not talking and I was
wondering
is there a Quantum relativity therapy
session that isn't it exactly wait for
my next book
exactly so when you so in traveling
Through the Wormhole there really the
answer is we you could end up anywhere
at any time is that sort of for the lay
person is that sort of one of the
answers there in a very crude way
mathematically yes uh but no one's ever
building Wormhole and we have no idea
how to build one or if actually most
physicists think it's not possible
because it requires negative energy so
who knows
um you know mathematically you can write
it down and get your negative energy
meet my mother
suck the energy right out of a room
exactly
why why are you killing me no no see you
meeting your mother makes you travel to
the post
exactly well so an important point that
you just glossed over there Sabina that
you go through into a black hole and you
have what we call proper time
but that's as applies to you so it
doesn't really make sense to ask what is
the time in a black hole because that it
has to reference someone who's making
the measurement of a time and then you
can get different measurements depending
on on Whose coordinate is behaving in
which way is that a fair way to sort of
add Nuance to what you just said yes
that's of course entirely correct and
it's also why people get confused about
this issue that it takes seemingly
forever to cross the Horizon of a black
hole if you've Fallen that's what you
see from the outside so so an observer
who sits outside and sees you falling
into a black hole which is see you
freeze as you get close to the Horizon
but in your own proper time if you fall
in uh it's a finite amount of time and
it's it's a finite amount of time that
it takes to hit the singularity if there
is a singularity in the black hole which
which we don't really know but assuming
that there is one it takes a finite
amount of time
so Paul we can solve that question by
you just visiting a black hole and and
see if there's a singularity there I am
going to go I'm taking Amtrak just so
much I was going to take Delta but you
know how they are they never get
anywhere on time but so I'm sorry real
quick and follow up to what you just
asked and Sabine and confirmed you're
saying again from a Layman's perspective
the person the individual and the time
and place at which that measurement is
it it is taking place
um specifically has an effect on the
issue and the concept of time it's not a
it's not a general answer in terms of
what we mean by time is specific to who
and when I think classically you can
think of this one-time system everywhere
right and we learned in relativity
that's just not the case right if time
is just another coordinate then you can
experience that coordinate in different
ways and so right uh that that's how I
think about it Sabina is that is that
fair yeah I think that's a pretty good
summary yeah yeah yeah so you
experienced straight time falling into a
black hole someone watching you it would
take forever for them to see see that
happen
perfectly legitimate wrist watches
making these measurements and so what is
the scientific measurement of a friend
telling me a long-winded story that
doesn't do anything for me in my life
the time they're actually slowly falling
into a black hole thank you thank you
that's exactly how I felt I couldn't
describe the feeling until now I'm
falling into a black hole which is why
when I talk to people now I want to wear
a welding helmet up so if I find that
the conversation's just going in a place
that's just doing nothing for me I just
put the helmet down and that pretty much
tells you that we're done that's the
evidence okay that's my yeah that's how
I work uh one more question this year
absolutely other universes inside the
black hole
um this is Ryan uh guernses and it says
hey everyone I want to know how possible
it is that inside black holes are
actually other universes yeah we've all
heard this Sabina and it's kind of it's
on the face of it it's completely
outlandish how can this giant sucking
machine called a black hole be the
repository of an entire universe
and Sabina you're going to answer that
question when we come back from this
break okay
because I want to know the answer too
very nice damn it what the hell is going
on inside of a black hole when StarTalk
Cosmic queries the big questions
continues
we're back StarTalk Cosmic Aquarius the
big question Sabina hussenfelder so
she's got a new book out on the big
questions existential questions uh in
physics and we're trying to get through
some of these bigger questions about
space-time black holes and the like uh
Sabina how do we find you on social
media
well you can find me on Facebook uh
under my name
uh or on Twitter under the handle
skdh as those are my initials just in
case you wonder uh and of course on
YouTube and of course you're a big
YouTube channel and Paul we find you on
social media where yes at SK k b a no
that's yours
I was wondering why I was getting all of
these really intense questions about the
quantum theory and you were probably
getting ridiculous comments about comedy
um no it's at Paul Mercurio
m-e-c-u-r-i-o on NBC Mercury Mercurio I
had to drop the first R because of the
Australian actor no it's because we have
a planet with that and you didn't want
to be confused for mercury I think
that's true
I get confused with planets a lot on
very often it's Ricky's got his own
Twitter stream just let you know exactly
exactly so Sabine I remember the
question from the second segment who's
the person who asked it Paul
this is Ryan guertez
from
no no no no yeah so are there hope we've
heard we've all read that you enter
black hole there's a whole universe
opens up in front of you could you like
get
have that make sense for any of us
please
yeah so uh we don't know what's inside a
black hole but uh it's not just the
answer Paul next question yeah basically
uh but that equipment can I just say
something the next question
okay but but the theoretical hypotheses
is what gives us this right
yeah so so that it's a black uh that
it's a a portal to another Universe uh
is one of the possibilities that people
have put forward uh you can do it
um basically the reason it works is that
um if you know one thing about
Einstein's theory of general relativity
is that space and time becomes curved
and you can curve it so much that you
create pockets and those Pockets can
become infinitely large so black hole
might be much larger in the inside than
it looks from the outside and indeed it
could be infinitely large so
mathematically you can stuff Another
Universe inside a black hole it's uh
it's indeed possible and given that we
don't have any evidence uh that could
tell us uh whether it's true or not I
would say yeah it's possible
here's your here's your Nobel Prize you
just I'm going to give it to you that's
the Russian dial Theory take it run with
it and you write up a paper and then but
in a sense isn't that it aren't you
saying that in a way that would mean
black holes in that black hole Universe
would have universes yes it would mean
that in principle Sabina right
yeah so that's basically what uh this
modern's idea of cosmological natural
selection is based on so you have uh
universes in uh black holes and those
universes make their own black holes and
so on and so forth so so you get an
entire tree of offspring of universes
and then he has some natural selection
stuff going on on them and I forget the
details but you wrote a whole book on
this he he did write a whole book on it
yeah it's called the life of the cosmos
I think so it would imply that the most
successful universes are the ones that
have the most black holes because they
would be making even more copies of
themselves so you step back and say what
is the most common kind of universe it
would be the kind of universe where the
laws of physics promote the maximum
number of black holes you can get and
that'd just be the naturals that's
borrowed right off the pages of of
evolutionary biology right
that's the idea yeah yeah does this is
this sort of related to this Loop
quantum gravity Theory and sort of he's
big on that but I don't know if they're
related what do you think Sabina I don't
think so I think they're pretty much
independent I mean I'm pretty sure you
can probably connect them somehow but
um but I think he was also big on that
idea as well if memory serves I mean
since we're talking about the universe
can you guys explain to me I love the
beginning sentences like that
since we're talking about the universe
well how is it how is it how is it that
Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart keep
making buddy movies and the universe
doesn't implode how is that possible and
either of you could address that for me
I would appreciate it do you want me to
move on to that we'll get our top people
working on that okay uh next just to be
clear Arnold Schwarzenegger made movies
with Danny DeVito okay
that is that is true tall and tall and
small tall and small stuff over
relationship and a pretty good movies
actually uh all right opinion or Theory
uh or opinion or Theory from your past
that's the title of this question this
is from Adam crowd they're not sure
where this person is from uh can each of
you give an example of a cherished
opinion Theory from your past maybe that
you defended publicly at the time but
now turns out to be completely wrong as
proven by new evidence I would like to
hear some good examples of the
scientific method as intended we don't
hold on to our beliefs and the same
contradictory
contradicting evidence
okay
what do you have going there
well I I wrote a whole book saying that
there hasn't been any progress in the
foundational physics you know I would
have been happy if there had been
something ruled out that I believed in
uh but I'm I'm afraid I can't really
come up with anything
um what what Springs to my mind though
is that I've changed my mind uh on Dark
Matter so I have a background in
particle physics and for a long time I
was pretty convinced there's probably
some kind of particle because if you can
use particle physics to explain it why
look any further
um now I'm I've pretty much drifted over
to the modified gravity side
oh oh blood drawn
[Laughter]
modified Newtonian gravity this is like
so we don't need dark matter we just
have to fix Newton's laws of gravity
because they're they're incomplete so
ooh ooh she's crossed over I'm just
letting you know [ __ ] that she
crossed over she just admitted that
well you know I said modified gravity
you brought in Newton so you know I I
think we we do need a relativistic uh
Theory uh Newtonian non-relativistic one
isn't going to do got it got it I have a
more holistic view of that question I
think it's a great question but a more
holistic view it's
I don't run around
espousing strongly things I believe in
for which
there is insufficient evidence to
justify that confidence
so I apportion the confidence I have in
my statements according to how much
evidence is available to it and and I
will follow the evidence wherever it
takes me so it's not like I have some
cherished belief that then has to be
thrown out the window and I'm kicking
and screaming while it happens I'm there
at every step of what the evidence is
telling us and when you have conflicting
evidence then people choose sides as it
as is true here with dark matter and
that's a fun part it's the bleeding edge
of physics and but the real problem
comes about and I think this is a an
important component of sabina's book is
that if you start
holding tightly to a belief system that
either has no evidence or only partial
evidence then you're going to fall
harder when that's if if the day comes
where you've got a discard the what
might be Decades of your invested hard
work
so where is that where is that fine line
like so okay if you apportion your
confidence based on the evidence
available
I mean it and I don't mean you I mean in
the third person just generally I mean
this kind of gets back to what Sabina
was saying in her book about sort of the
lack of advances in 50 years etc etc so
all right don't you have to kind of Walk
The Edge a little bit and say okay the
evidence shows me this I have this level
of confidence 30 I'm going to make some
assumptions and put myself out there and
make this statement or make not a
problem the question is how how
much emotional energy have you put into
it and Sabina this is what you've been
you found people were totally into what
they thought the universe should have
been
and and will not give it up like no
matter what and that's that's a problem
isn't that right Sabina
uh yeah I mean it's just it's
psychologically really difficult I think
if you you've spent a big portion of
your life uh researching a particular
idea that you're fond of and then the
evidence doesn't come forward as readily
as you thought it would and indeed
there's conflicting evidence what are
you going to do uh are you going to
admit that you wasted a lot of time of
your life right but I mean
wow you just described my life
but wait isn't that a title logical
argument on some level it's sort of like
if you're a great scientist or even an
average one and you've spent an X number
of years and it didn't sort of play out
the way you hoped or anticipated
isn't that knowledge in and of itself
that it's not playing out the way you
hope that you did make advances because
you disproved something that you thought
was otherwise but still you proved
something you see what I'm saying yeah I
see what you're saying uh and yeah
that's how it should be but you know
scientists are only human
um I I guess the the only thing that I I
have to add is that it gets easier if
you do it more often like I I've worked
on a lot of different things at this
point like in the past 20 years like the
phenomenology of particle physics and uh
quantum gravity and modified gravity and
a little bit statistical mechanics and
some foundations of quantum mechanics
and so on and so forth and you you get
used to giving up cherished ideas and
just moving on and doing something else
yeah so you like an idea but maybe you
shouldn't cherish it that maybe that's
the problem
you got to temper your passion I guess
right yeah all right so Paul we only
have like three minutes left so this is
on vacuum Decay from Sandra pagliani I
don't know where she's from what is most
terrifying to you vacuum Decay sneaking
up on us and suddenly destroying us or
the Big Rip which one is the most
probable to occur also given that we are
matter what are the chances that we bump
into anti-matter and vanish in a puff of
gamma rays I don't know why I had to go
so dark sorry about that so
clearly Sandra is having trouble keeping
a relationship and Sandra needs to get
help
she's a little on the dark side she's
the Debbie Downer of this uh particular
star talk session yes so big rip
vacuumed so and in sound bites what do
you have
so I think the best way to die would be
vacuum Decay because we would all die
without any advance warning and we would
all die together instantly
okay I feel good all right that makes me
feel good
and the thing about bumping bumping into
your anti-matter self there's there's
hardly any anti-matter in the universe
so uh that's not that
don't if that's one of your worries put
it lower on the list okay whatever you
know Sabina what you just did with your
answer you just gave Tom Cruise the idea
for his next movie where he saves the
universe from vacuum Decay by riding a
rocket in an improbable amount of speed
so I'm just putting that out there that
you just created the next movie coming
out uh should we move on to another
question sure sure okay uh infinite
planets Angus McNeil is there an
infinite amount of planets in the
universe if if there if there are I'm
sorry if there are an infinite amount of
planets in the universe then does that
mean that every possible planet from a
video game or a made-up world could
exist with real life physics now Angus
is 12 so it sounds to me like he's just
trying to justify playing video games
that's what it sounds like and his
parents are watching for the answer
let's see Ma I gotta play Neil Tyson and
Sabina said that this is
um so Sabina do you think he's really
thinking of the Multiverse there instead
of just the infinite number of planets
in our own Universe yeah it sounds a
little bit like a Multiverse idea
um so on on some level the answer might
be uh yes there could be planets with
other laws of nature on the other hand
uh I'm not sure that the kind of physics
that you get shown in video games is
actually consistent with the existence
of planets in the first place so you
have to be a little bit careful that if
you actually work out the maths that the
the universe still exists well it still
exists but in any you know I get I guess
in any Universe you're in the Grand
Theft Auto is still illegal like no
matter what happens where you are but
I've seen I've seen Mario American jump
off a ledge and then just Scurry back
onto the right onto the ledge there's
some really weird laws of physics and
yes you never see he never twists an
ankle he never blows out he never blows
out me it's just how is that how do you
steal a car in three seconds but an
important Point uh Sabina I think if you
imply this if you didn't say this
explicitly other universes might have
slightly different laws of physics in
them and so you'd have to create a
system of laws that would be compatible
with having planets we know our laws are
compatible with planets because we're on
one all right and and other evidence as
well Paul one last question see if we
can square one in uh this is Sam good
day I'm a tractor operator from
Australia so I listen to Star talk a lot
and I got to thinking about black holes
and the big bang and if no one actually
knows how the big bang started is it a
possibility that the Big Bang was the
result of a universe that had been
consumed by a black hole and popped out
of the backside of the black hole
whoa I say no because there's Flex tape
and when you have Flex tape ain't
nothing keep it together you ain't
nothing I saw that TV commercial
I really want to try the part where you
go into a pool and you put again anyway
go ahead so let me reshape that question
if the black hole can contain a universe
is that the same thing as popping a
universe out the other side and birthing
one is that is that a fair way to think
about that or not
yeah
and once it's pretty much the same uh
it's possible at least mathematically
you can do it you can have the universe
come out of a black hole and glue this
in the place where you normally have the
big bang it's one of the theories for
the beginning of the universe that
physicists have looked at
whoa so my boy on a tractor in Australia
is deducing the nature of the universe
and he's on a roll it tells you a lot
about the current state of physics oh no
or tell you a lot about how deep thinker
we got there on the on on the tractor
well I just want to say sam you just won
the Nobel Prize so congratulations get
off that tractor and come on down come
on down maybe maybe we're something that
maybe wear your tuxedo overalls for the
ceremony how about that
all right we got to end it there uh Paul
always good to have you man it's great
to be on all right and Sabina huffson
Felder it was Delight to have you uh
good luck with the book sometimes it
needs a little luck as well uh but the
topics are as you can see deeply uh of
deep interest to so many people
especially in our fan base so uh thanks
for agreeing to come on to StarTalk
wonderful to talk to your guests all
right I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always I've
been here to keep looking up
foreign
[Music]